a few months ago uh
i had a lot of stuff in my personal life
going on and it uh it triggered all my
childhood trauma
and i went back to therapy
and i i founded emdr therapist and
emdr therapy
helps you to process the trauma that's
stuck in your brain
and you have to go through a trauma
timeline before you actually do the emdr
therapy and a few weeks ago we were
doing my trauma timeline
and my therapist could tell i was
getting wound up and agitated
and she said to me
what are you thinking right now what are
you feeling what's going on with you
and i said to her
i wish
the scumbag who molested me
was in the room right now
so instead of the violent
bloody confrontation we had last time i
could ask him this time
where the [ __ ] it all went south for him
how
could he sleep at night
abusing young boys
where did he lose his humanity where did
hunting children
become his passion
and and how could he how could he live
with himself
how could he have a cup of coffee
quietly in the morning
and not be eaten alive by what he was
doing
i told her i just
i'll never get a chance to ask those
questions but i want to know just where
it all turned for him
my trauma
starts in the little town of stillwater
new jersey it sounds calm and peaceful
and tranquil
the palmskill river runs right through
the center of town
and it looks like an ideal place to grow
up
it's very rural
hunting and fishing and
sleigh riding and
skiing we have a ski resort in our
county
but we also had evil
hiding in plain sight in our county
i had an older brother
six years older than me
who was in the boy
scouts and his boy scout master
dennis pegg
befriended our family
and we took him in my parents owned a
restaurant back then and we had these
big sunday night meals and he would come
over and drink wine
he was lieutenant
in the local sheriff's department
and he worked at the county jail as a
lieutenant and he would tell stories
about beating inmates
and i was born with a hole in my heart
and at age
six the doctors came to my parents and
said
you know we've been monitoring clark for
six years plus and his whole has grown
to the size of a silver dollar we have a
six month window to operate
so at age seven i had open heart surgery
at mount sinai
here in new york city
and it was a life or death operation
and i have keloid condition where my
scars raised up
and my parents were so proud of me for
surviving this surgery that they used to
have me lift my shirt to all their
friends and collect a quarter
and they'd be like it might
my scar looked like a zipper they'd be
like show your zipper it was almost like
a peep show i was doing
and one of their friends was this scout
master slash lieutenant dennis pegg and
i had lifted my shirt for him
and it was about three four months after
my surgery it was a hot summer day
and i came in from outside we had a big
patio out back screened in patio a bar a
huge back back lawn
and i came in for a drink and to watch
tv for a minute and there was a knock at
the door the tv room was right next to
the front door
and i hear dennis pegg's booming voice
and i idolized dennis pegg next to my
father
he's who i looked up to the most
he was the scout master he was the
lieutenant he always had a badge and a
gun on him and i shot up out of my seat
and i let him in and he's like hey
little buddy and he tussled my hair
where is everybody and i said they're
out back
he's like oh let's sit for a minute
so we go into the den and sit
he's like i got a quarter for you can i
see your scar
and without thinking i'm like sure then
and i lift my shirt up to my chin
and he goes to me he goes how about i
give you a dollar if you let me touch
your scar i've never seen a scar so
raised up like yours
and i'm like sure then
and he takes his big meaty fingers
and he starts going up and down my scar
then he goes below my scar line to my
abdomen and he starts probing it right
around
my belt line
and he's asking is your stomach sore
from the surgery and i'm like no
after a minute of probing and rubbing
he's like okay
he's like here's your dollar
he's like this is our little secret he
goes we can't be buddies if you can't
keep a secret
and i said i can keep a secret then and
he's like all right here you go
i'm going to go out back and see
everybody i said okay
and that was his first
physical grooming act and he had me the
prick had me because i i
i was good at keeping secrets and that
would come back to haunt me
i lived at a lake community in
stillwater called paul and skill lake
and back then in the early 70s as soon
as you could learn how to ride your bike
your parents told you be gone
and be back at dinner time there was a
damn area down at the lake and there was
ball fields and basketball courts and
jungle gyms and then you had the lake
where you could
swim and there was fishing and all the
young kids congregated down at that damn
area
and that became dennis pegg's trolling
ground he would spend hours with us
fishing
teaching us how to fish where to fish
how to bait our hook
he did
he would stop by our house all the time
but he did all his one-on-one with me
out of the watchful eye of my parents
down at the lake where they
couldn't see
my parents told me back then never get
into a stranger's car
they didn't warn me
to never get
into their best friend's car
who happened to be a predator
at nine years old he's inviting me into
his pickup truck down at the lake to
split a six-pack of budweiser
canned beers
he tells me a story
that his friend just bought a farmhouse
and there was an old desk in it
and he opened up the drawers and it was
filled with pornography come come sit in
my truck i grabbed a bunch of the
pictures out of the desk
let's look at him and he's all giggly
and laughing i'm like okay you know i'm
thinking i'm going to see
some naked women i get in his truck
and he he he hands me polaroid after
polaroid of close-up of penises
and i'm like then
where's all the women
he's like oh those must have been in the
other drawer i'll get i'll i'll get some
out of the other drawer next time aren't
these funny though look at these and i'm
like
you know
and he's he's gauge
gauging me and he's testing me
he tells me back then back then the
marlboro man was the epitome of cool he
was on the back of every cover
and
dennis is always taking trips out west
and on a trip
out west
he tells me he meets the marlboro man
and he goes to me
wouldn't you believe it the marlboro man
is gay
and it didn't bother me at all he was a
great guy we hung out for three nights
and
and and hiked and we went to dinners and
he was just such a great guy
i don't know whether the marlboro man
was gay or not but dennis is is
trying to normalize i think
mail on mail behavior and he's trying to
test me also
and everything that beers
the marlboro man these are secrets
this is just between you and i
everything was a secret
and
on the other side of stillwater on the
other side of palm street lake there was
another area for fishing it was fishing
all along the river
but it was by the grist mill in
stillwater an old grist mill there was a
bridge and dennis would be like
the fish aren't biting here let's go
over by the grist mill
throw your bike in the back of my truck
and we'll go over there now dennis lives
just up from the grist mill dennis's
house
sat on a perch overlooking the
elementary school stillwater elementary
school
he could see when all the little league
baseball games were going on and he'd
come down from his house
and stand at the fence and watch all the
little boys playing baseball
but dennis would tell me throw your bike
in the back of my truck we'll go over to
the bridge by the gristville and fish
and he would always seem
to slip in the water
fall off a rock soak his shoe
or his boot or his sneakers whatever
he's wearing and be like i fell in i got
my feet wet come on let's we got to go
up to my house let me let me go up and
change
and then when we get there and give me a
beer
and he's
getting me comfortable going to his
house
at 10
he starts doing wrestling matches with
me
and again
this is our little secret buddy
he would let me
be on top like i'm pitting him he is a
265 pound hulking monster of a
lieutenant in the sheriff's department
but he would let me pretend like i'm
pinning him
and then something would switch in him
you could you could actually see his
eyes change
and they would dilate
and he would get aggressive
and get me on the ground and get on top
of me and start gyrating on top of me
at 11
we end up at his house
and he tells me
let's have a glass of blackberry
brandy and he fills a glass of
blackberry brandy up
chug it chug it down
and it's burning me
and he's like just finish it finish it
and then take a swig up here he's got
i'm 11 years old and he's got me
chugging a glass of blackberry brandy
and drinking a budweiser beer right
after it
and he's like we're going to play a game
called bumping logs
and he's like i'll be right back
and he goes into his
bedroom
and he comes back out
and it looked like he had stuck
something down into his shorts he always
wore those cargo shorts with the pockets
and i just thought he had stuck
something into his shorts i'm drunk i'm
11.
i'm trusting of this guy
and he says stand up and i stand up and
he pulls me into himself
repeatedly and he's like your log's not
ready yet let's get your log ready
and he sets me down on the chair and he
goes close your eyes and whatever
happens don't open them
and in the blink of an eye he slips my
shorts off me and starts giving me oral
sex
and my eyes
instantly open
and he's got his penis out jerking off
and i'm frozen in fear i'm gripping the
side of the chair
and i can't breathe
and my mind is racing and i'm paralyzed
i'm freaking paralyzed
and as a grown man that that's what
haunted me my whole life
is that i i froze whenever he touched me
he finished off
gave me another beer
told me this is our little secret what
happened here today
and to the best of my ability i just
tried to put that out of my mind
if you want to say i was lucky
i was lucky that i didn't live with my
abuser
i could go months
without an encounter down at the damn
area of seeing him
i've heard from so many people that
lived with their abuser and on a weekly
or daily basis they're getting abused
and it's just horrific
at age 12 he concocts
this giant story that he needs my help
and it ends up with me being at his
house
and driving to his house he picked me up
down at the lake area i'm like
i'm freaking out
going back to the house
and we got there and the house was
boiling it was a summer day but it
the house was excruciatingly hot inside
almost
as i look back on it now i wonder if he
didn't have the heat turned on
and we get in there
and he has me chug blackberry brandy
then he fills it up again come on come
on come on have another blackberry
and i was so nervous going back to that
house i actually wanted to have a
a drink
and
a budweiser my second glass of
blackberry brandy
and we end up
on his bed
and we end up
with our clothes off
and i end up with him behind me
in a bear hug with him behind me
and he starts raping me
and i start screaming
and i start crying
i grew up as an altar boy in the
episcopal church
but in that moment
i wondered where god was god didn't come
to strike this piece of garbage down as
he's raping me and i'm crying
i'm screaming i'm crying
and this
[ __ ]
whispers in my ear my 12 year old ear
just another minute
just another minute so he can finish
himself off
i felt like the only person on the face
of the planet
i know people feel alone sometimes in
their life they isolate themselves
at that moment i felt like i was the
only person on the face of the planet
nobody heard my screams nobody came to
my rescue it was just me and this evil
entity raping me
and what happened next
to me was worse than the rape that just
occurred he sat me down
cleaned me up like a nice guy
sat me down at his kitchen table got me
a beer
like two lovers who just you know had a
a great romantic experience and you know
let's have a beer afterwards
and he had what's called a [ __ ] dog
[ __ ] dogs have a long drawn out howl
and his dog heard my cries and screams
during the rape and started howling and
would not stop howling
dennis witton got his dog
brought it right in front of me
and said i want to show you
what will happen if you ever open up
your mouth about what just occurred and
he took his big meaty fist and he
started punching his dog punching his
dog punching his dog and i'm screaming
dennis please stop stop stop
and he's punching and punching and
punching and punching and his dog lay in
a peep at my feet
and to me that was worse than the rape
because i felt responsible for that dog
because it was only howling because of
my cries
the guy i looked up to next to my father
the most has just done the unthinkable
now he's beating his dog to death
unconscious to ensure my silence
he dropped me off
down at the lake reiterated
don't you say a word
and i didn't want to be near the dam
area where all the kids hung out so i
ran down the river with my bike i
ditched it in the weeds and i ran down
the river
and i just was rocking along the river
hugging myself
and at that moment my 12 year old mind
said we are never going to talk about
this talking about it is equal to
reliving it and we definitely don't want
to relive what just happened
i had gotten a dirt bike
for
christmas the previous year
and i wanted to avoid going down near
the dam area at all costs
so i started hanging out the rape
occurred the elementary school
stillwater elementary school
went up to sixth grade
they built a brand new high school a few
years prior
and they put seventh and eighth grade in
the high school
so i got raped the summer where i
graduated elementary school and before i
was going to start seventh grade
and to avoid
the damn area i started riding my dirt
bikes with older kids around the lake
and they all smoked weed
and i began smoking weed
on a weekly basis
i had no coping skills for the trauma in
my brain and i needed to dilute it
somehow
and we did that for me
if you had told me
three months prior in sixth grade at the
elementary school that i'd be smoking
weed i'd have laughed at it was
so far out of my little brains realm of
possibility and yet now i've been raped
i've had this dog beaten unconscious
dead in front of me
and i don't know how to
process it
and i'm smoking weed on a regular basis
my mother worked at the new high school
in the library
so every day i got to crank on my
my smile
for her for the teachers for my
classmates
i built up this big
outgoing personality
and charm
and it was
all a farce
it was just to fool everybody i let my
guard down one time
seventh grade in english class we got
given an assignment
the teacher
gave each student a letter of the
alphabet and said you have to write a
one-page
essay using that letter to start as many
words as possible in your story i got
given the letter s
and i wrote about being a slave on a
ship
where the shipmaster
was a gay guy
who every night would try to come into
my bunk to molest me and i had to keep a
metal pipe
at my side to beat him off with
this is what my
essay was about
and it raised no red flags with the
teacher she she gave me an a and said
use more paragraphs next time
and after that i was sealed shut
if people look for signs
and children of abuse
a few years bef
earlier i started playing with fire a
lot
pouring gasoline on stuff lighting it on
fire i lit our backyard on fire i let
the corner of our house on fire
seventh grade
i get arrested i get caught shoplifting
cigars out of uh
out of a store at the mall our local
mall
those are both signs
of sexual abuse arson
and shoplifting
i came home from school
and i thought i was real cute i had a
little safe in my room
but you could either use the combination
to open it or you could just
pull it real hard and it would open
and that's where i kept
pot
rolling papers in a bowl and i come home
and all three of those are sitting on my
bed
and my father walks in behind me
and he says
i am not putting up with this [ __ ] with
you
i already researched a military school
down by philadelphia you keep smoking
that [ __ ] and i'll send you to military
school
so he missed an opportunity to try to
open up a dialogue with me about why the
[ __ ] i'm doing this
why the [ __ ] am i starting fires why am
i shoplifting why why am i smoking weed
at 12 years old
instead
back then
as was the norm he took the
authoritarian approach
and he missed an opportunity to get me
to open up
he did
about a year after the rape
sit me down
and say i want to ask you something i'm
hearing rumors about dennis pegg
molesting inmates at the jail
he's like he's
he he was taking inmates home to mentor
them
and when he would get the inmates
upon their release young male inmates
obviously when he would get them to his
house in the middle of the night he
would pounce on them
and some of these inmates
ran out of his house and were
hitchhiking and the little stillwater's
a little
little town and they were hitchhiking in
the middle of the night in stillwater
getting picked up by the residents
and saying this guy offered me a place
to live to get my life back on track in
the middle of night he's on top of me
trying to sexually molest me and it
spread around our town like wildfire and
my father caught wind of it
and he sat me down and he said has
dennis ever touched you
this is really the only regret i have in
life i you know i've led a really
screwed up wild life
but i uttered to him no daddy never
touched me i could have began healing
right then
if i just could have found the courage
to open up back then
there was no agencies to treat abused
children the only ones you went to were
the cops and he was he was law
enforcement
and i didn't know who to trust or who to
turn to so i said no daddy never touched
me about about
another year after that
my father went to the local dunkin
donuts in our town and the waitress was
from our town of stillwater
and over a cup of coffee she's telling
my father
how her son who's a classmate of mine in
the boy scouts
was raped by
dennis my father comes home tells me the
story
and this time he says before you answer
my question
i just want you to know that you'll
never have to talk to the police you'll
never have to testify in court i will go
take care of dennis myself
you just tell me has he ever touched you
so is my father telling me he's going to
murder dennis
go beat him up
i don't know
it's one of those two
and as tempting as it sounded i just
couldn't bring myself to tell my dad and
i said no daddy never touched me
i go into high school
access to
alcohol becomes much easier
and
i become a heavy drinker in high school
i'm constantly at war with my parents
we used to go to keg parties in high
school me and my buddies
and get bottles of yukon jack
and it's a hard whiskey and we're
drinking yukon jack at parties and
getting bombed
i got caught on class trips drinking i
came into school drunk
got suspended the principal called me
down to his office and said
clark i just don't get
you you have
unlimited opportunity and yet you
squander it your grades are crap
you don't excel in sports you don't do
anything what's going on with you
and i felt this
i felt like this bile starting to
come up from my stomach through my chest
and it wanted out so bad it wanted to
just tell him what the [ __ ] i've been
dealing with
and it got up to here
and before it could come out i swallowed
it down i just said i don't know i don't
know i just shrugged my shoulders
i gave up i abandoned i knew i was smart
and i knew i could do no studying
and get c's maybe an occasional b and
that was fine with me i abandoned my
studies i abandoned sports
i go off to college
right after i graduate
a few weeks after i graduate high school
i get a drunk driving
i go off to college i went to
northeastern university up in boston
mass
and i i became a great student i had
college down to a science i could study
four nights out of the week and i could
be a blackout drunk three nights out of
the week
i went to college back in the 80s where
cocaine was like booming and i tried
coke for the first time i absolutely
loved it
it took away my insecurities my
self-loathing it made me outgoing
i tried other drugs
mushrooms psychedelics in college but it
was really coke that i loved coke and
drinking
i met the love of my life
we dated northeastern's a five-year
school we dated for six years
and when it was time for her to
when she was ready to take our
relationship to the next level she
pinned me down
and
you know i wanted to start a life
together and i just i told her i
couldn't she goes what do you mean you
care i just said i can't
i couldn't be intimate i could have sex
all i wanted but intimidate intimacy is
a totally different thing i just
couldn't do it
and she said i gotta i gotta
i gotta leave you then
and that haunted me for my whole life
that i missed out on her
my twenties
i never wanted to feel trapped
because trapped how i felt when i was at
dennis pegg's house
so i went from one career to another
i went from one relationship to another
i did one night stand after one night
stand after one night stand
my whole
thought process in my 20s was the
pursuit of sex
if i could just sleep with enough women
that'll make me that'll make me feel
fulfilled and
like a man and take away all the
self-hatred and self-loathing that i
have
and it didn't work
after a decade of that
i went into my 30s just feeling empty
feeling
like a big hole was within me and i
needed something else
to push the pain and the shame back down
and i found that in gambling
when i walked into those casinos
i could literally check my pain and
shame and self-hatred at the door
and i had an amazing run in the casinos
for five six years winning huge amounts
of money
and then i couldn't wait for the
weekends like any other drug you need
more and more i couldn't wait for the
weekends i needed a fixed earlier in the
week so i started sports betting with
the mob
within six months i was bankrupt had to
declare bankruptcy and i got in debt to
the mob for a large sum of money
from all my gambling winnings and i was
putting so much cash into the bank the
irs criminal investigation bureau paid
me a visit right to my house and did a
full audit
my later 30s i was importing steroids
i got a letter from division of homeland
security saying a package
addressed to me
got caught
with anabolic steroids in it and they
basically give you
a one time get out of jail free card
so i've got all these things in my life
i had bought a harley
i'm running with bikers
selling drugs and doing drugs with one
percent bikers
my
life which should have
been full of potential i'm just going
down one dead end street after another
i go into my 40s
when i went to my 30s i was unemployed
go figure
and my brother had a tire automotive
business and he asked me to join him and
we were going to open up a second shot
which we did
so i had nothing else to do so i joined
him
and
i go into my 40s
and
not knowing anything about ptsd
something
triggers my ptsd and i fall into a huge
depression
and
i don't know how to handle this
depression it was like this heavy wet
soaking wet blanket on top of me that i
couldn't get out from under
just swinging my legs out of bed in the
morning
felt like i had these giant tree trunks
and i'd have to talk to myself like a
little baby come on clark come on swing
your other leg out come on now stand up
and walk to the bathroom
[Music]
and not knowing how to combat this
i start drinking before work now
i start doing
little bumps of coke just to get me
through my day
working on working in the entire
automotive i would work on
backhoe tires loader tires truck tires
and i herniated a disc in my back and i
went and saw a doctor
and he prescribed me 30 vicodins
and i ate these 30 vicodins in three
days and i felt like superman on them
and i called them up and i'm like doc
those pills worked wonders i'm like i
feel like i'm 17 again bro
let's get some more there you go whoa
that was a little fast there buddy boy
he goes i'll give you 10 more and that's
it that that simply wasn't acceptable to
me so i knew people on the street that i
got coke and stuff from so
i don't like i'll just you know in my
mind i'm like i'll just find him on the
street and thus began a six-year pain
pill addiction
i was like a squirrel gathering nuts i
could have i could have 500 pills in my
drawer
and i'd still be worried because i heard
i heard this one time
when rush limbaugh
after his back surgery got addicted to
pain pills i heard this astronomical
number that he was taking 40 pain pills
a day and i just thought to myself
that's
friggin impossible
it's not impossible
i'm taken depending on the strength of
the pills i had up to two dozen a day
so i'm severely depressed i've got a
pain pill addiction i'm drinking before
work
i'm doing bumps of coke
and one day
after work i'm in a deli getting a
coffee making a coffee at the island
and the door opens up
and i look up
and it's my rapist
dennis pegg
and he sees me
and he yells out to me like we're best
friends hey clark
and i start instantly going into a panic
attack my heart's
instantly racing a million miles an hour
and my palms are sweaty and my mind just
starts swirling
and i feel my joints locking up like i
did when i was a little kid when he
would touch
me and walking in right behind him is a
young boy
about the age he raped me at
and that young boy calls him the same
nickname he used to insist i call him
and i heard that nickname
and it just ripped open everything
that i had repressed for the last 30
years all my pain and horror and shame
and rage and violence
came instantly bubbling to the surface
and dennis is starting to make his way
to me
probably to
give me a hug or a high five or a
handshake and i just ran right by him we
shoulder bumped i ran right by him i
hopped in my pickup truck i sped out of
the parking lot i started going down the
road flying down the road i started
punching my steering wheel yelling
[ __ ] i started spitting on my
floor
and my life
collapsed that day
less than two months later i walked out
of the family business i was in with my
brother i could no longer swing my legs
out of bed in the morning
it was like climbing mount everest and i
said i'm [ __ ] done climbing mount
everest
and i never looked back
and now i got free time on my hands i
got pain
and hatred and shame and rage bubbling
out of me
for decades
all that filled my mind
was hatred rage violence pain shame
pornography drugs alcohol that's what i
filled my mind with
for decades you fill your mind with that
[ __ ] for decades no good is gonna happen
in your life
and my life was about
to take a left-hand turn south
instead of buying a gram of coke every
now and then i'm buying ounces of coke a
week
i'm using and selling
i got my pain pill addiction
people think
that only the degenerates do heroin that
only the homeless people on the street
do heroin
drugs will lie to you drugs don't care
who they go after
when my pain pills started running low
and people didn't have any
somebody said
i got some dope man
it's a hell a lot better than pain pills
are a hell of a lot cheaper
and i'm like [ __ ] it
and i start doing heroin
from the age of 12 when i started
smoking weed on a weekly basis i began
blowing through all my boundaries i set
in life
that that that rape the the the bumping
logs the
the wrestling with a hard on on top of
me
all that [ __ ]
made me so i couldn't live within my
boundaries anymore
boundaries became meaningless
and now
i've just blown through
another boundary i'll never do i told
myself i would never ever ever ever do
heroin and now i'm doing heroin
i'm doing so much cocaine that i'm
popping 8 to 12 xanax a day
i'm drinking massive amounts of alcohol
i don't care if i live or die
so many nights in the middle of the
night
i couldn't remember how many xanax i
popped i'm like should i my heart's
racing so from the coke i'm like should
i pop more xanax shouldn't i should i
take some pain pills instead how many
pain pills have i taken
i'm like i'll just be like whatever
whatever bro
and one night
i had told a friend
i'd lent money to a friend and he was
coming over
to
he was going to pay back the money by
power washing and staining the cedar
siding of my house
and
the morning
of he was gonna come over on june the
12th
i woke up that morning after
a three-day coke bender passed out for
maybe two hours
did a line of coke poured a glass of
wine
sat in bed put on the news and it was
the start of jerry sandusky's
molestation trial jerry sandusky
was a coach out at penn state
and he'd been running a boys camp and
molesting all these boys for decades
and i saw this guy getting out of his
lawyer's car and buck button in his
suit jacket and i just started yelling
curses at the tv i started spitting on
my bedroom floor
i just was hugging myself and rocking
back and forth on my bed
and i was at this point i'm doing so
much drugs i'm avoiding family of
avoiding friends but that day
seeing that trial
i had to get out of my house i spent the
rest of the day out
drinking
doing coke popping xanax
i stopped at
an italian restaurant i always
frequented and there was a guy in there
who had burned me on a business deal
and he and i had words
and then i went home to meet my friend
who was dropping off the equipment to
power wash and stain the house
and i told him about seeing the guy who
burned me on the business deal in the
restaurant
and we're having a glass of wine at my
kitchen table and my friend says that
guy's got to be number one on your hit
list
and before i could stop the words
i just couldn't i couldn't control my
mouth
i said he's
he's actually number two on my hit list
the piece of [ __ ] who raped me as a kid
is number one
and there's dead silence
my friend's just staring at me and for
the first time in my life i've never
told anybody about the ring i just let
it out
my friend starts asking me some
questions who is he where does he live
and within 15 minutes
we're driving to his house to go
confront him
i'm like let's confront this
[ __ ] i look from outside his
house in ran up his driveway
his front door was open his storm screen
door was
shut
and there he was sitting there watching
tv
it's 9 30 at night
he doesn't have a care in the world
i start going into that panic attack
again
i feel my joints just
it's like a paralysis comes over you
even even 30 years later
that guy still had that power over me
and before i could freeze in his
driveway
i marched up to that screen door and i
ripped it open
and here i am
a childhood rape victim with his
who's just ripped open his screen door
at 9 30 at night
and this [ __ ] whack job looks over
his shoulder calmly as can be
and goes hey
how are you
and it
it just seemed like the most bizarre
thing in the world to say he didn't like
get on his knees and start pleading or
say i'm sorry i i always thought you
might come by here
ah okay you know let's talk
he just says hey how are you i go hey
how am i [ __ ] let me show you
how the [ __ ] i am
and i raced across this [ __ ] living
room
and i had a knife in my hand and i
started stabbing at him
and he started throwing haymakers at me
and a violent bloody
struggle ensued
at one point he connected with a shot
squarely to my draw and i started
falling down
and i grabbed his shirt with my left
hand
to hold myself up
and i came down with i yelled you
[ __ ] and i came down with the
knife and i put the knife straight
through my hand and i severed all the
ligaments
and tendons in it
the fight lasted just a couple minutes
he fell down in blood
and i knelt down in front of
him and i looked him in the eye and i
said it's not so fun raping little boys
now is it i slit his throat
and people always want to ask me did all
your problems
disappear when you did that and i'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me
i'm like to go murder even though i
murdered a pedophile to go murder
somebody i had to get down in the gutter
like a dog
no
no it didn't cure all my problems it
just added a whole nother dimension of
problems to my already mountainous
problems i had
and before i left that house
in my bloody footprints
i walked over to the bedroom he raped me
in and i spit on his bed
i was arrested the next day
i woke up the next morning in bed
and when i opened my eyes i said what
the [ __ ] have you done clark
you just flushed your [ __ ] life down
the toilet bro
in my mind that was so polluted with
drugs and alcohol said if we could just
get some drugs and alcohol in our system
we can come up with a plan
and like a lunatic i yelled out to my
empty bedroom i agree
i got up
i poured a bunch of xanax into my hand i
took them i went out to my kitchen i
poured a glass of wine and i look out
the window and my street is lined
with at least a dozen cop cars i'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me already
and my stomach just dropped to the
ground
i chugged that glass of wine i poured
another one
i walked out to the slider in the back
of the house and i looked out the back
and there's cops hiding behind trees
behind rock walls i'm like what the [ __ ]
and out of a loudspeaker right here
mr fredericks
come out of your house with your hands
up
and one thing i did i had seen a state
trooper friend of mine from high school
a few months prior in a bar and he's
like hey come out to the car i got some
hats and some uh state police shirts
take a couple i'm like yeah cool
before i go walking out i go into my
bedroom and i put my state police shirt
on i'm like this should get me out of it
i knew it wouldn't get me out of it but
i just thought
[ __ ] it if i'm getting arrested by the
state police i might as well get
arrested wearing her shirt
and as i started walking to my front
door
i called out to god god who at 12 i
our relation my relationship with god
changed at 12.
it became a relationship of me getting
into
the riskiest behaviors and calling out
to god you owe me bro
i'm doing drug deals with people from
patterson buying ounces of coke
i'm like you owe me bro you better get
me through this
that was my relationship with god
i said to god as i was walking to that
front door i'm like
god
please let one of these cops shoot me
when i step out my front door
just let it be over i'm done with this
life it's over bro
and i stepped out onto my front porch i
put my hands out and i waited for the
crack of a gun
[Music]
just so i know i'd be out of my misery
and i never heard that crack of the gun
instead i was taken to the state police
barracks
and when i was in the state police
barracks this lieutenant
came in
to the holding cell and the first words
out of his mouth were
i want to apologize to you
i go
i go what the hell are you apologizing
to me for
and he goes i've known about this
scumbag for a long long time
and he goes and i apologize that i could
never arrest him
he goes i can't build the criminal case
based on rumors and innuendos i need
cold hard facts and i need victims and
whatever he did to you victims
to keep you silent
prevented me from arresting him and i
apologize
and he left the the cell and i was like
wow
at first i felt
i felt good you know about him
apologizing and then i just started
fuming i started fuming i'm like every
[ __ ] person knew about this scumbag
and yet i got to be the one to put an
end to him
and now i just flushed my life down the
toilet
why the [ __ ] did i have
every single person around knew what
dennis pegg was doing with young boys
and yet i got to be the one to put an
end to his 45-year reign of terror and i
got to pay with my life
a little while later that same
lieutenant
came back into the holding cell
and he goes to me he goes look dude
he goes my detectives are waiting in
another room with
detectives from the prosecutor's office
and they're waiting to interrogate you
you're gonna get pulled out of here in a
minute or two
if you go into that
room
and open your mouth you could totally
[ __ ] your whole life
he goes you're in deep [ __ ] right now
you don't need to get in deeper [ __ ]
you go into that room you exercise your
fifth amendment rights you keep quiet
you request a lawyer and you don't say
another word
and he asked me three times do you
understand what i'm telling you and i'm
like i got it
and without him telling me that i might
have just he could he said to me later
on i could tell you had mailed in your
life i walked back in that holding cell
and i could just see the look in your
eyes that your life was done and it was
i righted a wrong
for a lot of people
including myself
and i just forfeited the rest of my life
and this guy didn't want my life to be
forfeited
so i went into that
interrogation room i requested a lawyer
and that was the end of the interview
i had to get emergency hand surgery
and under the anesthesia as soon as i
came out of it
they took me to the to the jail
and i woke up in the middle of the night
not knowing where i
was and eventually after surveying my
surroundings it came to me that i was in
the county jail where they put me was in
a suicide cell
and i was in that suicide cell for four
weeks
and they had me in the right spot
because at that point i just wanted to
die i had no desire to keep living i had
no desire to do life in prison
and now i'm in the very jail you want to
talk about how low somebody can sink i'm
in the very
jail being held for murder of a
lieutenant who spent his whole career
working in that jail
and it seemed like he had been protected
so i'm thinking they're going to give me
the beating of a lifetime in this place
and one by one
the guards that would come in to do cell
checks in that suicide cell would be
like
hey look man keep your mouth shut
don't talk to anybody i'm hearing a lot
of [ __ ] about this guy
i didn't know him i didn't work with him
i'm hearing he was an animal
just keep your mouth shut
next guy would come in and say something
similar
my third day there a guard came in who i
knew from the street
and he's like my man how are you and i
go are you [ __ ] kidding me bro i'm
like i'm shitty
he's like i know i know he goes do you
know what's going on in the community
i'm like what
he goes somebody started a free clark
campaign he's like there's bumper
stickers everywhere he goes
he goes every [ __ ] car has a free
clark sticker on it and i'm like really
he's like yeah i go they don't view me
as a monster they're like he's like are
you [ __ ] kidding me peg was the
monster everybody wants to know why he
was still walking the street
i was like man
the sheriff's department when they have
a fallen comrade they lower the flag to
half mast and they wear blue ribbons
they were ordered not to lower the flag
to half mass for dennis pegg and not to
wear blue ribbons
that should tell you
what they were hearing about him
and then i
finally after four weeks in a suicide
cell i had to go to three weeks in an
isolation cell because i had a cast on
and they viewed that as a weapon
and they wouldn't allow me into general
population with my cast on
so until that cast came off i was in a
cell by myself isolated
i finally get
put up into general population
and there's these overhead lights that
come on in your cell that like shock you
awake at shift change in the morning
they come on and they literally are so
bright and have such a
an evil hum to them they shock you awake
and i would wake up every morning
cursing
cursing my existence cursing where i was
cursing that light
and i called out to god that day
i had been unable to pray
and anytime i tried to close my eyes to
pray just violent images or sexual
images would flood my mind
so instead i yelled out to god that day
in my cell i said god you either have to
help me find a way to kill myself
or heal myself i can't go on another day
feeling like this
and
like i said i was not a bible toter
i had abandoned god
and yet that day in my cell i heard an
internal voice loud and clear say
you have to pick up a book and start
reading
my case
had been
all over the country it was on the front
page of the l.a times baltimore sun
all over it aired in 37 countries around
the world i got books
self-help books spiritual books
meditation books yoga books the bible
books from all over the country were
coming in to me
you can only keep so many books in your
cell almost every cell on my tier had my
books in
and when i heard that voice say you have
to pick up a book and start reading i
looked at the books in my cell
and there was a one tiny little book
and i i took that book
which i had never even paid attention to
and it was man's search for meaning by
holocaust survivor victor frankel
and i said well it's a small book i'll
start with this one
and in it he talked about finding
purpose in life and meaning in life even
in the circumstance of being in a
concentration camp
and there was a sentence in there that
that ignited something in me the
sentence was
i'm gonna i'm gonna paraphrase it when
you're faced with a intolerable
situation that will not change
you must change yourself
and i read that and i'm like
all right my situation isn't going to
change i could possibly do life in
prison i got to change myself
and i read that line over and over and
over i highlighted it
and i would just read
when your situation isn't going to
change you have to change yourself
and i dedicated myself after reading
that line to begin
healing there's no therapist in jail
there's a therapist but it's just
to prescribe drugs and my lawyer said
don't say anything to the therapist
because the prosecutor can
can get her records so i'm like alright
so i had no one to talk to in there
but i decided i was going to start
healing
i just began reading and reading and
reading
and i would take
maybe one thing out of a book and apply
it to myself i read this book the power
and now by eckhart tolle
and this book was about taking back
control of your mind using mindfulness
if you had told me when i'm riding
harley's
doing lines of coke going into strip
clubs
selling drugs to one percenters
that i'm going to read a book called the
power now about mindfulness and it's
going to change my life i would have
backhanded you and said get out of here
and yet i read that book
i almost underlined the whole thing
sometimes i would
i could only get through a couple pages
it was a heavy book and it was deep and
i wanted to i wanted to absorb it
and i wanted to take back control on my
mind because for 24 7
my mind either was focusing on the past
abuse
and the murder or it was facing life in
prison
so i read and i read and i read and i
finally picked up the bible and i read
the bible front to back
after three years of sitting in the
county jail i got offered a plea deal
enough other victims came forward
but they didn't want to and they
and the prosecutor even said in court
one day
and this this is sort of funny that i'm
in the jail for murder where the guy
worked his whole career and yet the
prosecutor's telling the judge i don't
think i can get a fair trial your honor
coming to work every day i'm seeing free
clark stickers on on cars how am i going
to get an impartial jury
so they finally gave me a plea deal to
second-degree manslaughter which carries
five to ten years
about my fourth month of incarceration
my mother came for a visit at the jail
and while she was standing in line to
come see me her minister walked out of
the jail he had been in to see some
other kid kid that their parents his
parents asked them to go visit their son
and he went to see him he saw my mother
and he gave her a hug and then he
grabbed her by the shoulders
and he he looked at her
eye to eye and he said joan i want you
and your son to start praying on the
number five as in a five-year sentence
my mother came in for the visit
and she tells me the story about praying
for the number five and this is like my
fourth month that i was locked up i'm
facing life i'm suicidal i'm depressed
and i say to her mom
you gotta pick a number that's a little
more realistic a five is not going to
happen
and she said to me son
i believe in god i believe in miracles
and i want you to start believing in
them too
and i knew i was
putting her through a lot of pain and i
said all right mom
i will
and from that day forward i started
praying on a number on the number five i
started asking god for a five year
sentence i started meditating i read all
these books on meditation
and i started putting a five into my
meditation
i read books on using a mantra to quiet
your mind
and i would put a five into the mantra i
repeated all day long to my in myself to
in my mind
i'm repeating this mantra
so now fast forward
to accepting this plea deal
and my lawyer prepared me that when
we eventually go for sentencing he's
like no judge especially on a murder
case
is going to want to be on the low end
they're going to they're going to want
to be on the high end of the scale so
just prepare yourself
i'm like alright
i finally go for sentencing
and in court on the record
the judge gives me a five and apologizes
for having to send me to prison for a
single day
he says i know that you only did what
you did because of what was done to you
and when i got taken out of that court
and put back in the holding cell
it just dawned on me that i got the five
that i had been preying on that i
scoffed at my mother for
and i couldn't believe
that the impossible became possible
i went to prison at northern state
prison in newark new jersey
in my first day there a therapist came
to my cell and said i followed your case
on the news
and i just saw your name come across the
computer i can't believe you're here she
goes will you start therapy
and i said absolutely
i had to finally surrender
i resisted change my whole life i
thought i was a big bad tough guy i'll
just do things my way
and i finally my way didn't work
obviously
and i finally decided to surrender
and to let anything and everything come
into my life that could take my life in
a new direction
i had no desire to go back to the animal
i had been
so here i have to go to prison to get
therapy for the first time in my life
and my second one-on-one therapy with
her she said i run a group therapy class
in prison for childhood trauma
would you join that and i said sure
and i'm in there with latin king gang
members blood gang members
muslims christians
and we all had these [ __ ] up
childhoods and we're all
sharing our story in front of each other
and we're crying in front of each other
and we're hugging each other and that
group therapy class was the greatest
healer i could have ever got in
so as shitty as prison is
at least i got that group therapy class
under my belt
my therapist also came to me one day and
she said i can't believe it clark for
the first time in a new jersey prison
they're going to offer a meditation
class it's a 15-week vipassana
meditation class she goes there's
limited seats i want you to sign up and
maybe you'll get in
so i signed up for it and i was one of
15 people to get in
for two and a half hours on a friday
night while you got all this insanity
swirling around you i'd be in a
classroom
getting to do
meditation quietly and calmly
i got
released from prison on december 30th of
2016 so basically the first of the year
of 2017.
and i had led this selfish
indulgent lifestyle and i still had a
little bit of selfish in me
and when i say that because i decided i
wanted to file
a lawsuit against the boy scouts and i
went and saw a law firm and they read me
the law
new jersey law and the guy said as the
law states
you have no
recourse for a lawsuit
and he goes there's advocates
who have been working
for 15 years to get a new law and they
haven't gotten anywhere yet
maybe you can join them and your story
is so over the top that you can sway
some senators and congress people
to pass a new law
and i'm like
meh
he goes i got the numbers of the
advocates i'll set up a meeting here in
my office i'm like cool
so i went in for selfish reasons just
for myself
and i walked out of there becoming an
advocate for everyone in the state who
had been abused
i started meeting with senators
lawyers for the catholic church
i got to testify before the house
judicial committee
and two years
after becoming an advocate
and people telling us you will never get
a new law passed in new jersey
we got we went from the worst law in the
country
to the strongest law two years of being
an advocate i was in trenton new jersey
to see the final vote and it voted
it was voted in unanimously
when i was locked up in prison
i heard that internal voice for the
second time as i sat in my cell quietly
one day
loud and clear saying to me you're going
to become a motivational speaker
[Music]
and i
i had been afraid deathly afraid of
getting up in front of people and
speaking in college i'm doing shots of
vodka at eight o'clock in the morning
before i gotta go do reports in front of
the class
and i think it was because i had all
this [ __ ] all this garbage inside of me
that i'm carrying around like how can i
stand up in front of people they're
gonna
they're gonna see all this crap they're
gonna see that i'm a fraud
and yet i heard that voice say you're
gonna be a motivational speaker i just
i threw up my hands i'm like whatever
and i thought to myself how's a dude
coming out of prison for murder
ever going to get a motivational
speaking career going
less than two months out of prison
before i became an advocate
one of the pastors who used to come into
the jail and teach bible study said
you've got to come to my church he wrote
me on as in prison he's like you got to
come see my church it's a huge church
and when i went to see him he's like
we're doing a uh
a water baptism
and he goes
we're baptizing people in tubs that were
made by new jersey prisoners he goes how
ironic would that be for you
to get baptized in a tub made by your
fellow prisoners and i'm like that'd be
pretty cool let's do it and i had to
read this testimony in front of like a
congregation of like 500 about why i was
getting baptized
and in the audience was this
lady from a place called jenny's house
and jenny's house is for abused children
and she heard my testimony and she
reached out to me
and she said april is sexual assault
awareness month
i'm presenting at centenary college
would you like to be my guest speaker i
was like absolutely so here
less than four months out of prison
where i had no idea i'd ever become a
motivational speaker this door is
getting opened by god for me
and from
the time the law got passed in new
jersey i concentrated
more on speaking
i spoke in rehab center after rehab
center after rehab center
i spoke at churches i spoke i went back
to the jail where i had been held for
murder for three and a half years and
got to speak to the inmates there
a director of a play off-broadway play
called blackbird based on molestation
reached out to me and asked if i'd be
guest speaker after the play on stage
and i'm like absolutely
twice i i
i went and spoke on stage after the play
ended
nbc did a documentary on me the
producers of nbc did a documentary on my
case
and i got on the tamron hall
daytime talk show
and from being on that talk show i got
offered a speaking contract by a firm
out of la
who wanted to represent me as a speaker
so that little voice i heard in that
prison cell
saying you're going to be a motivational
speaker
and again i scoffed at it
sort of just threw my hands up
here
a few years down the road i just get
offered a contract by a speaking firm
and i share this stuff
to try to give people hope
that's the one thing that always kept me
going people are like
how have you survived all the [ __ ]
you've survived and i'm like i always
held on to that little glimmer of hope
i went through life without any purpose
without any meaning all i was trying to
do was just stay one step ahead of my
pain
and now
helping other victims open up
helping them speak out
letting them know they're not alone i
always felt alone in the world like
nobody else could could understand the
pain i was carrying inside well there's
a hell of a lot of people who understand
the pain i'm carrying inside
and i always held on to hope and that
always kept me going if you if you can
just retain a little bit of hope
it can keep you motivated and i stayed
motivated
when i was locked up i wrote a
manuscript
of the first half of my life and i i
dreamed of like getting a book deal
and i wrote three book proposals and and
got nowhere with them
and out of the blue simon schuster
read my last book proposal and just
offered me a contract which i just
signed a few weeks ago for a book deal
i just finished up
a multi-episode
documentary a producer reached out to me
and said your story is amazing it's
inspiring
i want to give
your voice to other people to help them
open up
and we just
finished up this multi-episode
documentary filming it
and
that college sweetheart
who i lost 30 years ago
who i hated myself that i couldn't
commit to her i couldn't take the next
step with her
after 30 years i finally reached out to
her to apologize to tell her why i
couldn't commit to her
she used to say to me she used to we'd
be lying in bed together and i would
just stare off into the distance and she
would be like this and there would be
nothing
and she'd be like hey hey hey
you're like what
she goes where'd you just go
i'm like what are you talking about she
goes
you just left me she's like where'd you
where'd you disappear in your mind to
and i'm like i have no idea what you're
talking about
so she always knew there was something
troubling me
but didn't know what it was
and i had reached out to her and
explained my story
explained
how i finally had meaning and purpose to
help others now
i explained all the good i was doing
with my life i'm 10 years sober
and we got together for coffee two weeks
after i reached out to her
and we fell madly back in love
so i just want people to realize that
i mean i sunk
to where i was suicidal i was held in a
suicide cell for four weeks i was put
into jail for murder for murdering
a lieutenant who worked in that very
jail it doesn't get much worse than that
and yet a few years down the road
by holding on to hope and by
taking chances and not caring if i
failed and throwing as much mud against
the wall as i possibly could
one thing after another started coming
through in my life and now
just the opportunity to reach people on
a large scale and get them to open up
when people hear my story they relate to
it
you relate to people that have been
through the same fire as you
and breaking your silence is the first
step to healing
and i don't mind throwing all my garbage
out to the world if it will help the
next person break their silence
i learned this line in therapy
it's from the aaa blue book but it's
it's it's so true it's called it says
we are only as sick as our secrets i had
secrets
up to my chin
and i was sick i was sick inside
so speak out break your silence
don't hold secrets in
and let's begin healing
thank you
you